[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de Parlement Hebdo 26 minutes
pour revoir le meilleur de l'actualité à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat et on
accueille cette semaine Rachid themal
bonjour vous êtes sénateur du Val d'Oise
et président délégué du groupe
socialiste au Sénat
et dans l'actualité Marlène Schiappa
face au sénateur de la commission
d'enquête sur le fonds Marianne la
ministre a tenté de justifier
l'utilisation de ce fond créé à son
initiative après l'assassinat de Samuel
Paty Mohamed Sifaoui était lui aussi
auditionnée son association et celle qui
a obtenu la plus grande subvention du
fond Marianne
l'Assemblée nationale ne touche pas à la
liberté d'installation des médecins
l'amendement transpartisan qui prévoyait
de réguler l'offre sur le territoire a
été rejetée il avait été déposé dans le
cadre d'une proposition de loi de la
majorité pour mieux lutter contre les
déserts médicaux
et puis on parlera avec notre invité de
la LPM la loi de programmation militaire
en discussion désormais au Sénat une loi
qui prévoit 413 milliards d'euros pour
permettre à la Défense et aux armées de
faire face aux nouvelles menaces la
commission d'enquête du Sénat sur le
fond Marianne a donc mené cette semaine
des auditions cruciales pour mieux
comprendre cette affaire la ministre
marine Chapa a essayé de minimiser
devant les sénateurs sa responsabilité
dans les dysfonctionnements de la
gestion de ce fond sans censé lutter
contre la radicalisation Mohammed
cifaoui qui a dirigé l'une des
associations mises en cause c'est lui
défendu de tout détournement de fonds
publics les explications de Jonathan du
priez
c'était la dernière audition et sans
doute l'une des plus attendues des
sénateurs dans une ambiance tendue la
commission d'enquête sur le fond
Marianne a interrogé Mohamed Sifaoui
excusez-moi je pense que vous devez
garder et vos nerfs et votre maîtrise
vous savez je suis quelqu'un d'assez
entier j'ai le moment où on me respecte
plus je vais aller sur un autre temps je
vous le dis tout de suite protagoniste
clé du dossier l'essayiste était
responsable éditorial de la principale
association bénéficiaire du fond
Marianne avec 355000 euros en plus de
cette subvention Mohamed cifaoui a admis
devant les sénateurs avoir bénéficié en
plus d'un contrat de consultant
issu de l'organe chargé de distribuer
les crédits du fond une double
rémunération qui interroge les
parlementaires ont aussi tenté de
remonter à l'origine du versement de la
subvention à son association Marlène
Schiappa la Ministre en charge à
l'époque l'aurait encouragé à déposer un
dossier
quant à minuit sort pour vous saluer et
pour vous dire je compte sur vous
est-ce que c'est encouragé à mettre en
application un projet ou pas les
conseillers de la ministre vous disent
la ministre apprécie énormément le
projet que vous nous avez présenté
elle croit en ce projet sauf que la
ministre des mains fermement cette
version auditionnée mercredi Marlène
Schiappa a démenti tout lien avec
mohamedifaoui et renvoyait la
responsabilité de l'attribution de ces
crédits à son cabinet et à
l'administration en charge du dossier je
vous dis que je n'ai à aucun moment ni
prioriser moi-même ni demander de
prioriser le dossier de Monsieur cifaoui
et j'ajoute que je n'avais aucune raison
de demander à prioriser le dossier de
Monsieur Sifaoui et que je ne l'ai pas
fait des explications qui n'ont guère
convaincu le président de la commission
d'enquête sénatoriales je crois c'est
que effectivement elle était là accusée
de rien et qu'elle était là pour
répondre à nos questions de la manière
la plus précise qui soit malheureusement
sur beaucoup de sujets on a plus senti
de la défausse que de
que réellement une présentation claire
des faits la commission d'enquête
désormais close les sénateurs publieront
leur conclusion avant le 13 juillet date
de fin de session parlementaire
rachithémalov vous étiez l'un des
sénateur qui avait demandé la création
de cette commission d'enquête sur cette
affaire du fond Marianne on l'a vu dans
cette audition la ministre Manan Chapa
c'est un peu défaussé de ses
responsabilités dans les
dysfonctionnements de la gestion et de
la mise en place de ce fond mariage ça
vous étonne cette stratégie de la
ministre c'est assez surprenant quand on
est ministre on a un cabinet et dont une
administration doit être responsable
d'ailleurs le porte-parole du
gouvernement l'a dit je crois à la
sortie du Conseil des ministres et dans
ces auditions là on a vu plutôt moi je
souhaite d'abord saluer le travail du
Sénat qui en capacité façon
transpartisan de mener ce type de
commission d'enquête mais aussi revenir
sur les deux préfets qui ont été
auditionnés celui qui était à l'époque
directeur du cpdr et celui qui était
directeur de cabinet du comité
interministériel de prévention de la
délocan c'est de la radicalisation
et le directeur de cabinet de marine
Chapa les deux je crois ont été assez
honnêtes d'ailleurs on dit très
clairement les choses à la fois ce
qu'ils avaient fait et puis aussi ils
ont aussi dit notamment le préfet Gravel
il a aussi dit que l'on lui avait une
forme de pression politique une forme de
commande poétique qui ne répondait pas
aux canons j'ai envie de dire habituel
de travail de sérieux donc ça moi je
trouve ça bien après Marlène Chapa je
crois qu'elle ne répondait pas en fait
aux questions de la commission d'enquête
mais plutôt elle s'interrogeait sur
d'autres éléments puisque vous savez
qu'il y a des enquêtes qui sont ouvertes
il y a le parquet nation financier je
crois qu'elle le répondait surtout pas
avant ce parquet influencier puisque
finalement elle était ministre elle
était après au courant de rien un après
décider de rien et elle avait le choix
entre assumer sa responsabilité ou
passer pour quelqu'un qui était assez
légère dans la gestion d'un ministère et
donc ça nous inquiète sur cette gestion
justement on a dit plusieurs fois lors
de cette audition au Sénat je ne sais
pas est-ce que c'est normal qu'une
ministre ne sache pas ce qui se passe
dans son propre cabinet mais non mais je
crois que
tous les élus quand vous êtes mère
président moi-même j'ai été
collaborateur de cabinet vous aurez fait
à votre Ministre et en tout cas de fait
le ministre ou le maire doit assumer la
responsabilité de son administration de
son cabinet et par ailleurs le directeur
de cabinet a indiqué que sur une
association SOS raciste la ministre
avait dit non tout se lèverait il est
indiqué qu'il y a eu des échanges entre
monsieur CIFA notamment et Madame Chapin
donc tout ça existe elle c'est
totalement défaussée enfin et encore des
fossés c'est pour être pour être poli je
crois qu'on a assisté
je crois que ça a été en direct le crash
du ministre très honnêtement puisque
maintenant tout le monde comprendra que
soit n'assume pas ses responsabilité
soit finalement n'était pas ministre la
question c'est que durablement rester à
son poste selon vous
il y a une seule responsabilité celle du
prénom République qui nomme une première
ministre et donc de fait
si le prix en république estime qu'elle
doit rester c'est son souci à lui avec
tout ce qu'elle cela suppose s'il
souhaite s'en séparer c'est son souci à
lui voilà et je pense que notre rôle
nous en tant que Sénat c'est d'avoir
mené cette commission locale il faut
saluer également le travail de
journaliste qui ont mis en exerne
notamment tout cela donc nous faisons de
commission d'enquête et comme vous le
disiez le d'ici le 13 juillet le
président claudonal remettra avec le
rapporteur Husson son rapport et puis le
Sénat ensuite a attiré des conséquences
de tout cela je rappelle que les
rapports du Sénat c'est pas de savoir on
n'est pas la justice mais c'est de voir
ce qui s'est réellement passé s'appelle
le contrôle c'est dans la conscience et
aussi faire des préconisations pour
éviter d'autres situations de cette
nature là quand on lance un fond il y a
aussi des règles à manifestants à mettre
en place qui n'était pas le cas à ce
moment-là mais politiquement est-ce que
vous diriez que Marine Chapa est
affaibli aujourd'hui avec cette affaire
je n'ai pas de sentiment que jusque là
ça soit dire une personne structurante
du gouvernement et qui est qui j'ai
envie de dire n'est pas quelqu'un qui
qui pèse qui qui structure le débat
poétique globalement je rappelle que il
fut un temps ou à la même était expulsé
du valmant avant de revenir par la
petite porte donc moi je versais encore
une fois c'est la seule petite
gouvernement de choisir toltonisme c'est
pas celle de l'opposition voilà est-ce
qu'au vu de l'audition de Mohammed CFA
oui vous estimez que ce dernier a eu une
forme de traitement très privilégiée
sans avoir forcément
des compétences supérieures à d'autres
acteurs du monde associatif qui aurait
pu être choisis que retenez-vous de
cette audition
moi je trouve que je vais pas aller sur
la forme et sur le fond il a dit très
clairement qu'il avait été approché par
Mans Chapa et son cabinet pour rentrer
dans la dans l'appel à projet voilà les
choses sont claires il a expliqué en
quoi il pouvait faire il a expliqué que
très vite on lui a dit qu'il y aurait
pas de suite vraiment donc tout ça s'est
arrêté la question encore une fois
revient surtout à pourquoi se font là
alors vous avez aussi faut pas l'oublier
et je le dis vous avez dans en France
des milliers d'associations on peut pas
dire plus qui bossent au quotidien sur
des des choses aussi similaires et que
ces associations là n'est pas que lui
pourquoi ce fond là particulièrement
travaillent des gens bénévoles qui font
ça au quotidien en plus de leur travail
etc et ben on donne notre sentiment que
finalement il y a du tripatouage alors
que des millions de Français sont dans
un station et le travail très bien et
qui d'ailleurs association qui demande
des crédits qui n'ont pas et quand ils
voient quand ces personnes à voient ce
ce scandale là effectivement on peut
être juste écœuré justement ça va jeter
le discrédit sur le travail de des
associations qui dans l'ombre contre la
radicalisation
il y a globalement mais moi justement
c'est pour ça je souhaite le rendre
hommage grâce à votre antenne je pense
qu'il faut que les Français entendent
bien que les associations bossent
aujourd'hui sur le terrain et non pas
attendu le fond Marianne et non pas
attendu madame Schiappa et je voudrais
appeler encore une fois d'autant plus
choquant que c'est après l'assassinat de
Samuel Paty qui est qui vivait dans mon
département qui es-tu dans mon
département que cela a été lancé donc
comment à partir d'un drame qui aurait
dû ressouder la nation on termine avec
ce ce j'ai en dire je ne sais pas c'est
des pieds nickel ou des barbouzes on n'a
pas bougerie mais c'est scandaleux donc
moi je souhaite endommage encore une
fois il faut saluer un mois il se
rappelle la mémoire de sympathise qui
est arrivé dans quel cas mais c'est je
salue le fait que nous ayons une
commission d'enquête au Sénat qui va
justement comprendre la mécanique folle
des 10 ou 15 jours qui a conduit à
justement à cette descente aux enfers
jusqu'à l'assassinat odieux de Samuel
Paty donc c'est une bonne chose
elle a été validée par le Bureau du
Sénat et par je le dis salut les
millions de Français dans les
associations qui ont coûtenti un boss et
qui ne sont pas de nature de celle que
vient de voir acheter mal on va parler
de l'actualité à l'Assemblée nationale
la question des déserts médicaux était à
l'ordre du jour avec la discussion d'une
proposition de loi d'un député horizon
majorité pour améliorer l'accès aux
soins sur le territoire français un
amendement a été ajouté au texte pour
proposer de réguler la liberté
d'installation des médecins amendement
rejeté malgré un soutien transpartisant
explication de Stéphanie Despierres la
loi ne touchera pas à la liberté
d'installation des médecins des députés
issus de 9 groupes politiques parfois
même du camp présidentiel ont pourtant
fait railler toute la semaine pour
amender une proposition de loi du député
horizon Frédéric walthou pour lutter
contre les déserts médicaux ces élus
veulent limiter l'arrivée des médecins
dans les zones bien pourvues dans
l'espoir qu'ils aillent plutôt là où il
en manque c'est le socialiste Guillaume
Garraud qui mène la bataille nous disons
à nos médecins
n'allez plus vous installer là où les
besoins de soins sont déjà pourvus mais
allez vous installer où vous voudrez
ailleurs là où les besoins de santé ne
sont pas pourvus là où vos patients vous
attendent ça dépend une régulation
drastique ça n'est pas de la coercition
il y a une liberté totale qui reste sur
93% du territoire français liberté
totale depuis des années la France
cherche la formule magique contre les
déserts médicaux mais pour le
gouvernement et l'état-major du groupe
Renaissance se remettent serait pire que
le mal en disant
car on le
é Calero moi c'est ça l'effet immédiat
qu'il se produira le ministre de la
Santé a aussi mis en garde contre un
mauvais signal envoyé au médecin cet
amendement s'il est voté c'est une perte
durable de la confiance des
professionnels de santé et comment
comptez-vous comment imaginez-vous
engagez cette grande réforme du système
de santé sans la confiance des
professionnels
l'Assemblée a voté contre l'amendement
de Guillaume Garraud le député
socialiste promet de continuer le combat
quand même cette démarche transpartisane
pour faire aboutir changer la loi et
permettre de plus de régulation dans
l'installation des médecins selon la
densité de l'offre de soins sur les
territoires ça n'a pas abouti est-ce que
vous le regrettez bien sûr je le
regrette et moi je salue la démarche de
mon collègue socialiste Guillaume
Garraud qui a su frédérer comme vous
l'avez dit parce que c'est quoi la
question qui est posée aujourd'hui en
fait c'est on parle la liberté des
médecins à juste titre mais on oublie la
liberté des Français de pouvoir se faire
soigner donc ça veut dire que pour vous
la liberté d'installation des médecins
est plus importante que l'égalité de
l'offre de sortir pour ceux qui ont voté
contre l'amendement oui moi je dis qu'il
y a deux libertés c'est des médecins
mais il y a aussi celle des Français de
pouvoir se faire soigner parce que
d'abord je vous rappelle que les déserts
médicaux moi je vois bien en
Île-de-France même dans mon département
de l'Oise il y en a je pourrais vous en
parler des heures durant dire par
exemple aujourd'hui le maire de
Cergy-Pontoise qui vient de créer une
maison de santé il a toujours général
s'ils vont trouver mais ça permet il y a
des spécialistes il y a déjà en quelques
jours 700 personnes qui sont inscrites
parce qu'il y a pas d'offre de soins et
quand il y a une offre on oublie souvent
c'est la question la tarification par
ailleurs parce que quand vous êtes des
conventionné je veux dire c'est pas une
chose oui il y a une double système que
dans cette fin là on oublie souvent
cette partie là qui après le coup quand
vous avez même un médecin donc
aujourd'hui dans 93% du territoire
national il y a pas de sujet le sujet
portait sur 7% 7% dans 7% on demande à
ce qu'il y a un régime dérogatoire qui
permet que la liberté de se soigner soit
permise c'est aussi simple que cela et
moi je ne vois pas pourquoi pendant un
ou deux ans les médecins n'auraient pas
une contrainte dans leur dis pas venait
en tel ou telle ville leur dit bah
rentrer dans les 7 % vous êtes libertis
vous installez dans les 7% du territoire
qui sont pénalisés parce que les
Français sont pénalisés donc oui c'est
aujourd'hui un vrai drame pour tous les
territoires parce que je le redis
souvent l'Île-de-France et aussi un
désert médical dont bon de territoire a
commencé par le Val-d'Oise qui est mon
département architeml est-ce que ça veut
dire que les sénateurs socialistes vont
reprendre redéposer cet amendement de
Guillaume Garo pour réguler
l'installation des médecins si jamais
cette proposition de loi arrive au Sénat
alors pour être totalement transparent
nous avons aussi des débats
socialistes moi je fais partie de ceux
qui comme garrot veulent aller plus plus
dynamique parce que ça n'enlève rien à
ce que pense mes autres collègues moi je
crois qu'aujourd'hui on a fait le côté
on va débattre on va discuter on va
concerter ça ça déjà fait on nous
annonce le ministre dit oui mais il va
falloir attendre un peu qu'on forme plus
de médecins mais tout le monde sait très
bien que former un médecin c'est près de
10 années ce qu'on dit tranquillement ce
que dit le ministre ce que dit le
ministre également c'est cher française
et français vous devrez attendre 10 ans
pour aller voir médecin et je vous
ajoute un mot parce que ce qu'on nous
dit souvent c'est que il y a un joli
trouver des médecins quand on les trouve
le coût du médecin quand ils ont des
conventionné et donc comme il y a pas on
va à l'hôpital et on tombe sur la crise
de l'hôpital qui fait qu'il y a sur plus
de d'arrivée à l'hôpital avec les
conséquences qu'on connaît parce que
l'hôpital lui-même
on peut pas dire aux Français l'hôpital
explose attendit 10 ans voilà donc je
lui parle là aussi je pense que la
macronie fait preuve encore une fois de
de manque de réactivité et de mesure à
l'issue des débats François Braun c'est
félicité en disant la démocratie
parlementaire a gagné est-ce que vous
pensez que le gouvernement envoie un
mauvais signal en refus en ayant refusé
cet amendement garrot moi je condamne la
position du ministre un ministre qui
devait régler le problème de l'hôpital
rien n'est réglé qui devrait régler le
problème des médicaments rien n'est
réglé il y a une commission d'ailleurs
d'enquête en ce moment Sénat sur la
liberté fin sur la capacité à rompre
réduire les erdicales des armes du coup
pardon excusez-moi les déserts médicaux
il n'y arrive pas non plus c'est un
échec total et d'ailleurs j'ai cru
comprendre dans ce qu'on lit dans la
presse qui serait le même sur la
sellette bon j'ai envie de dire que
souvent là adore utiliser des mots
historiques jamais vu l'arrêter c'est
que c'est beaucoup de bruit pour pas
grand chose sauf sauf quand il faut
pénaliser les plus pauvres l'APL ou
encore une fois la est prête avec les
deux années supplémentaires Rachid est
mal vous êtes aussi vice-président de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées du Sénat et
cette commission cette semaine à
modifier le projet de loi de
programmation militaire avant son examen
dans l'hémicycle du Sénat fin juin alors
ce projet de loi il porte à 413
milliards d'euros le budget de nos
armées sur la période 2024 2030 et la
commission du Sénat a décidé d'accélérer
cette hausse budgétaire dès les
premières années de cette période on va
écouter sur ce point le président de la
commission Christian Cambon qui a été
interrogé par François Vignal et Fabien
militaire qui jusqu'en 2027 continuent à
dépenser 3 milliards et puis les 100 en
quelque sorte l'effort aux nouveaux
présidents de la République qui viendra
en 2027 or nous nous pensons que c'est
maintenant que nos forces armées ont
besoin d'un rehaussement de leur de leur
plan de charge de leurs activités de
matériel et donc nous avons proposé un
amendement qui lisse en quelque sorte
cette somme considérable et va permettre
de dépenser non pas 3 milliards mais 3
milliards 6 chaque année
tout en restant dans la même enveloppe
incitait mal effectivement le
gouvernement augmente considérablement
les moyens de nos armées mais en
concentrant cette hausse après 2027 pour
ne pas mettre dans le rouge dans ces
prochaines années nos finances publiques
c'était la mauvaise stratégie
d'abord je rappelle actuellement nous
sommes dans une loi de programmation
militaire et le gouvernement avait déjà
fait le coup de la pré présidentielle
il la stop bon d'abord nous les
socialistes nous avons fait le choix au
Sénat de bonifier LPM de la transformer
et ce que nous avons fait en commission
avec le président Cambon et notre groupe
se socialiste nous avons modifié
pas tel quel la LPM vous on a bonifie on
l'a structuré mais pour une raison
d'abord simple vous la modifier comment
par exemple d'abord je vous rappelle que
nous sommes aujourd'hui dans une PM ou
le gouvernement refuse d'en faire le
bilan que bah c'est surprenant et
d'avoir un travail de perspective sur
c'est quoi les risques il y a pas eu le
travail là il y a eu un travail qui a
été fait en chambre mais pas avec le
Parlement donc d'abord nous avons
travaillé sur cette question là bon
petit 2 vraiment communique beaucoup sur
les 413 juste une seconde
alors comme il y a 24 et 2024 2025 qui
sont sur les deux LPM c'est 97 milliards
donc 413 - 97 Vous contestez un peu le
chiffre là je conteste pas je vous donne
les chiffres c'est pas moi qui les
invente vous prenez l'alpm actuel qui va
nous sommes elle va jusqu'en 2025 donc
dedans il y a 2024 et 2025 nous sommes
d'accord c'est la future la future elle
parle de 24 donc à 97 milliards entre 30
et 50 milliards d'euros d'inflation
d'accord vous additionnez ça vous
retirez à 413 et je suis comme je suis
gentil je retire je ne tiendrai pas
compte des 100 milliards d'encours déjà
dans le chargeur toujours pas payé par
l'État donc je pense qu'il faut avoir un
peu de modestie dans cette affaire là
globalement mais de l'argent c'est vrai
c'est pas historique nous notre sujet
notre sujet de socialiste c'est de se
dire aujourd'hui au moins il y a un son
de défi la guerre en Ukraine mais
également ce qui se passe en dopacifique
ce qui se passe en Afrique c'est quoi
les compétiteurs face à nous c'est quoi
les risques jusqu'à les types de guerre
potentielle et de menaces potentielle et
à partir là on construit une armée donc
c'est ça notre travail à nous donc nous
avons amélioré la loi sensiblement pour
que des gens commissions par exemple
nous avons au moins posé l'article
premier totalement qui n'existait pas
pour dire c'est quoi le cadre de la
défense c'est quoi les objectifs de
défense sur la question budgétaire parce
que celle qui intéresse par rapport trop
de questions et bien nous disons plutôt
que de mettre l'argent plutôt vers la
fin de LPM mettons dès aujourd'hui parce
que la recherche développement lancer
des programmes ça coûte de l'argent il
faut maintenant amorcer la pompe c'est
une bonne idée de renforcer de
construire un nouveau porte-avions le
ping selon son nom de code c'est une
bonne idée ça vous dites que c'est bien
mais nous sommes favorables
effectivement à un porte-avion nous
savons que le Charles de Gaulle actuel
va arriver à une fin de course nous
avons déposé un amendement au niveau
c'est notamment Gilbert Roger pour mon
groupe qu'il a déposé au nom de groupe
c'est on demande aussi des tunes sur la
capacité à maintenir en état le
porte-avion Charles de Gaulle pour qu'il
soit dans la Méditerranée quand même de
protège pendant que le nouveau
porte-avion pour être lui déployé
beaucoup plus loin ce qui veut dire
qu'on n'aurait pas un coup de d'un
deuxième porte-avion mais donc nous
avons fait proposer des choses comme ça
nous avons aussi proposé des amendements
au compte accepter pour améliorer la vie
concrète financière aussi des troupes
voilà nous avons les socialistes ont
amené beaucoup de beaucoup de choses en
attendant rachète t'es mal si vous le
voulez bien on jette un petit œil à l'AG
enda à venir auparavant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et mardi les sénateurs entameront
l'examen dans l'hémicycle du projet loi
industrie verte un texte censé
décarboner notre industrie mercredi le
ministre du Travail Olivier du socle
sera auditionné par les sénateurs sur
son projet de loi pour le plein emploi
un texte qui prévoit notamment de
conditionner le versement du RSA à une
activité de case de 15 à 20h par semaine
Olivier du socle qui sera à l'Assemblée
nationale des Lundis puisqu'il sera
auditionné par les députés mais cette
fois sur le projet de loi pour le
partage de la valeur qui est issue d'un
accord entre les partenaires sociaux
avec pour but mieux partager les
bénéfices des entreprises et mardi les
députés vont réexaminer la proposition
de loi pour le plafonnement des loyers
après l'échec des discussions avec le
Sénat racheté mal on va finir cette
émission par quelques questions
politiques on le voit dans la
gendarmementaire le gouvernement borne
s'active avec de nombreux textes la loi
industrie verte la loi de programmation
militaire le projet de loi pleine emploi
est-ce que cela peut lui donner un
nouveau souffle politique après la
séquence de la réforme des retraites et
lui éviter notamment un futur
remaniement dont on parle celui qui fait
qui on parle beaucoup d'urbaniement ça
peut Emmanuel Macron le printemps c'est
lui qui a donné 100 jours c'est lui qui
a menacé son propre gouvernement donc
c'est le problème il vient de la
macronie en elle-même en son sein le
problème n'est pas de savoir aujourd'hui
bornes pas bornes la question c'est
comment on fait passer les textes il
nous a pas échappé qu'à l'Assemblée
la représentation du gouvernement elle
est à la majorité relative bon et ben
n'arrive pas à faire passer ses textes
donc le problème il est il est toujours
le même rien n'a changé depuis juin 2021
depuis juin 2022 la méthode Tex par text
comme le disait Elisabeth borne vous
vous y croyez pas a-t-elle marché depuis
un an
qui passent mais oui mais vous avez des
textes qui ne passent pas je rappelle
que pour le budget par exemple il y a
pas loin de 15 ou 17 ans
oui donc vous voyez bien qu'il y a un
problème il y a un problème de majorité
structurel à l'Assemblée on parle comme
si ça faisait longtemps mais ça fait à
peine il reste quatre années est-ce que
face à de nombreux défis que nous avons
devant nous on peut avoir Goldman qui se
dit peut-être d'être bien écoutez bien
que non regardez sur la question de
l'immigration moi je conserve que tout
ça est une on voit bien d'ailleurs
maintenant tout le monde court après
l'extrême droite mais sur le texte
immigration il le mette l'ortie dormait
il lui retire ça dépend quel ministre
quel moment puis finalement il faut
négocier bon c'est pas avec qui comment
ça n'est pas sérieux et je pourrais
comme ça continuer avec d'autres
exemples dans dans les textes donc nous
nous considérons qu'à ce stade il y a un
problème de de majorité fiable et dans
la durée de dans le quinquennat mais il
faut que Monsieur Macron comprenne enfin
le résultat des élections de juin 2022
parce que je crois que c'est ça le vrai
souci ils n'ont pas compris que les
Français ne l'ont pas de majorité
absolue en juin 2022 et rachit email il
y aura des élections cette année en
septembre 2023 le 24 septembre les
élections sénatoriales la moitié du
Sénat et renouveler et dans cette
campagne des élections sénatoriales et
bien il y a des tensions au sein du
Parti socialiste notamment à Paris
puisque le patron du PS Olivier Faure
refuse valider la liste des candidats
socialistes au sénatorial à Paris au
motif qu'elles ne contiendrait pas de
candidats en position éligible qui
serait favorable à la ligne politique
d'Olivier fort c'est à dire plutôt
pro-up mais qu'elle ne contiendrait
uniquement que des candidats proches
Dany dalgo qui est hostile justement à
la nupeste est-ce que ce ne sont pas les
divisions du Parti socialiste qui
rejaillissent dans cette campagne
satoriale je crois pas d'abord que les
choses soient claires il y a aucun
endroit en France il y a une liste du
peste donc au départ c'est pas pro
contre du pèse c'est pas la vraie vie de
lecture je peux me permettre non non le
partialiste il reste deux trois
fédérations où il y a encore des enjeux
discussion dont Paris il y aura des
rendez-vous tout le reste a été adopté
par le Bureau national par sa liste donc
là n'invente pas d'histoire il n'y a pas
et tous les socialistes sont favorables
à ce que notamment avec le Parti
communiste il y a un accord qui a été
signé mais également avec les Verts si
on a trois accords qui a un accord donc
non les socialistes sont rassemblés il
reste des cas il reste des cadeaux sur
Paris ce qu'ils font Paris l'approche
d'Olivier fort selon vous mais n'en
faites pas de Paris et de la
ce qui se passe ailleurs ce n'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui il y a un désaccord
entre la liste qui a été adoptée par les
militants parisiens dont tout le monde
des militants parisiens et la vision
qu'on a Olivier Faure il y a il est
prévu de plus d'un seul qui a des
échanges dans le 10 15 jours qui
viennent je laisse je laisse pour les
échanges pour les chances de la gauche
même s'il y a pas de vrai union de la
gauche lors de ces sénatoriales mais
d'abord il y a je viens de vous dire
qu'il y a du monde à gauche donc je
viens de vous dire qu'il y en a déjà
le PC il y a un accord
discussion mais d'abord ça n'a jamais on
a on n'a jamais eu des accords parfaits
partout je vous donne l'exemple que
parfois quand il y a quelque sorte bon
il faut faire ça donc dans ce qu'on veut
en fait les socialistes on veut passer
jusqu'à 100 parlementaires de gauche au
Sénat et c'est pour ça que nous
proposons que le PC libère d'avoir un
accord merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
invité et merci à tous d'avoir suivi
cette émission
[Musique]